a newly released indictment reveals the
terrifying ordeal of two Hollywood
actors who were kidnapped and held for
ransom Los Angeles police say Daisy
McCracken and her friend Joseph Capone
were kidnapped in May of 2017 Capone was
held for a $10,000 ransom which the
kidnappers forced McCracken to pay three
suspects face multiple charges John
Blackstone shows us how the plot
unfolded actress Daisy McCracken played
Donna in the 2002 horror film Halloween
resurrection but it was her own
real-life experience that was truly
terrifying according to the unsealed
indictment alleged kidnappers Keith
Andre Stewart Jonte Jones and amber Neal
showed up in McCracken's Los Angeles
house when they arrived
Stewart allegedly pistol-whipped
McCracken's friend and fellow actor
Joseph Capone the indictment says the
kidnappers then placed black hoods over
the two actors heads and drove them to
Jones house once there the defendants
allegedly stripped Capone naked starved
him and forced him to stay in a bathtub
for 30 hours during that time Jones and
Neal allegedly forced McCracken to
provide them with a $10,000 check for
Capone's release they then allegedly
took McCracken home where she was able
to escape and call police who later
arrested the three
[Music]
on Monday cell phone video captured the
moment one of the alleged kidnappers was
really with guns drawn police surrounded
amber Neel and took her into custody
it's unclear why she was released after
her initial arrest last year
the video caused a stir online forcing
an explanation from the LAPD although we
are limited in what information we can
release we can confirm this individual
was arrested on a felony kidnapping
warrant Neal Jones and Stuart are
charged with 17 total felony counts and
could each face up to life in prison for
CBS this morning John Blackstone Los
Angels